quantum entanglement allows particles to be linked regardless of the space between them this is so counterintuitive
that even Einstein didn't think it was true in today's episode of kissk in the classroom we'll talk about how Bell's
theorem proved Einstein
wrong welcome to kuit in the classroom in this series we'll use kkit to explore some fundamental concepts commonly
covered in Quantum Computing related courses each video will also be accompanied by an interactive module
Linked In the description below so be sure to check that out in the quantum coins video we discussed how measuring a
Quantum superposition is an inherently probabilistic process like flipping a coin in some ways but how do we know
this could it be that a Quantum particle secretly hides a predetermined outcome of a measurement but we somehow fail to
capture this information in our theory in the early days of quantum mechanics this question was the subject
of heated debate with two main factions in one Camp was Einstein who believed that quantum mechanics was incomplete
that is that it was missing some variables that were necessary to fully describe a system Einstein thought that
these so-called hidden variables if found would resolve some of the seemingly paradoxical and probabilistic
aspects of quantum mechanics in the other Camp was Max Bourne Bourne argued
that the probabilistic description given by quantum mechanics is all that is specified by nature in other words it
isn't just that we don't know the state of a particle prior to measuring it it's that the particle has no definite State
before it's measured for decades many thought this disagreement was a philosophical question that might never
be resolved after all in order to learn anything about a system we need to measure it how can we possibly learn
anything about the nature of a state prior to its measurement then in 1964 the physicist
John Bell found a way in his paper bell examined the statistical correlations between measurements of a pair of
entangled particles if prior to measurement the states of the particles were determined by some unknown hidden
variables then Bell found that their correlations had an upper limit on the other hand when he calculated the
correlations predicted by quantum mechanics he found that they violated this limit so he had found a way to once
and for all differentiate between Einstein and Bourne's view all that remained was to actually experimentally
test these correlations with real particles to see whether they obeyed the hidden variable statistics or they
violated that rule these tests were performed with increasing precision and sophistication
over the years and they're some of the most significant experiments of modern physics they were so groundbreaking that
they earned three physicists the Nobel Prize in 2022 but these days anyone can perform a
bell test all we need is a little knowledge of kcit and access to an IBM quantum computer in this video I'm going
to walk you through the logic of Bell's inequality then I'll show you how we can test Bell's predictions on an IBM
quantum computer Bell's inequality involves a few different measurements and layers of logic and it can be a
little tricky to follow but we'll go through it step by step and in the end it'll be worth it we're about to show
that entanglement is real and Einstein is wrong that's not something many people can say they've done so here's
what Belle proposed let's say you have a way to produce many copies of an entangled pair of particles physically
these pairs could be produced through a Decay process where one particle decays into two if you watch the video on the
stern gerlock experiment you know that particles can have an intrinsic angular momentum called
spin say one spin zero particle decays into two spin 1/2
particles then each of the spin 1/2 particles can be measured to have either spin plus2 or minus
one2 also called spin up or spin down but since they decayed from a spin zero particle then the two must combine to
have a total spin of zero also so if one is measured to be up the other must be
down and vice versa these particles form an entangled pair that looks like this
so if one is measured to be up the other one is down and vice versa let's say particle one flies off to the left or
the minus X Direction where a researcher who will call Lucas measures its
spin then particle two similarly flies off to the right
where another researcher Rihanna can measure that spin Lucas and Rihanna can independently
rotate their measurement devices to choose to measure the spin of their respective particles along any direction
perpendicular to the particle's direction of motion if we send many copies of the entangled state to Lucas
and Rihanna they can collect measurement statistics if they always measure along the same axis these statistics will not
be very interesting every time one measure spin up the other measure spin down and every time one measure spin
forward the other measure spin backward and so on but if the two researchers measure along different axes we may find
something more interesting let's give Lucas and Rihanna three axes along which to
measure we'll call these axes a b and c and they're each separated by
120° the question we will ask with this experiment is if Lucas and Rihanna are free to measure along any of the three
axes how often will the two obtain the same sign clearly if Lucas and ranum happen to measure along the same axis
say axis a they can never get the same sign since the particles must combine to have spin zero but when they pick
different axes how will their measurements be correlated if at all according to Einstein this quantum
mechanical description of the particle state is incomplete he thought there must exist hidden variables that
predetermine the outcome of all possible spin measurements since without that entangled particles would have to
somehow communicate the outcome of their measurement to one another instantaneously if one was measured to
be up way over here the other must instantaneously know to be down over
here these hidden variables could be any complicated set of instructions for the outcome of experiments but the point is
that the spin state of each particle separately is determined so no communication is necessary